two million six hundred and eighty two
thousand seven hundred and sixteen tests
for coronavirus have now been carried
out in the UK and that includes a
hundred thousand six hundred and seventy
eight tests carried out yesterday two
hundred and forty six thousand four
hundred and six people have tested
positive and that's an increase of two
thousand six hundred and eighty four
cases since yesterday nine thousand four
hundred eight people are currently in
hospital with coronavirus which is down
thirteen percent from this time last
week and I'm very sad to report that
those who have tested positive for kovat
19 across all settings thirty four
thousand seven hundred and ninety-six
have now died that's an increase of 160
deaths on yesterday and because that's
saying we offer our condolences to the
friends and family of every individual
who's passed away during this
coronavirus pound pandemic this is a
challenging time and as we chart the
right course over the weeks and months
ahead our overriding priority remains to
save lives whilst also at the same time
preserving livelihoods and allowing
people to return over time and as and
when it's safe to something resembling
more normal way of living so on the 11th
of May we set out a roadmap to provide
the information the advice and the
reassurance to businesses to public
services to other organizations and to
employees and citizens up and down the
country I want to thank everyone who is
making the adjustments and engaging with
us in government to falter the path
ahead in a sure footing and sustainable
way now of course we recognize that
people have concerns that have questions
and we want to work together with them
and with everyone involved to provide
the necessary confidence and reassurance
in the next steps that we're poised to
make that approach is summarized in the
slides which if we could now have them
up on the screen please and you'll see
from slide 1 and as people will be aware
we've established a new kovat alert
system with five levels each relating to
the current level of threat posed by the
virus
the alert level is focused on the rate
of infection known as the r-value as
well as the total number of Corona
Corona virus cases overall and that
alert level helps us to determine the
social distancing measures that we need
to fight the virus so the lower the
level the fewer or the less restrictive
the measures that we'll need at any
given time and since the lockdown began
at the end of March
we've been at level four as indicated on
the slide and thanks to the hard work
and the huge sacrifices across the UK
and the progress that we've made as a
result of that particular in relation to
compliance with the social distancing
measures we're in the process of moving
from level 4 to level 3 on slide and we
will do that through a number of very
careful and deliberate steps slide to
please so you'll see that last week the
Prime Minister set out the first of
three steps designed to carefully modify
the measures that had been put in place
and by gradually easing certain measures
we can begin to allow people to return
to something resemble resembling a more
normal way of life the choices we make
what we are asking the public to do what
we're asking them not to do are designed
to avoid the very real risk of a second
peak that would overwhelm the NHS and of
course risk turning a temporary economic
painful moment for the country into
permanent damage to the UK economy at
every step will closely monitor the
impact of easing restrictions and in
particular the impact on the spread of
the virus and it's only by collecting
and monitoring the data that there that
we will be able to take the next step
which is indicated as step 2 on the
slides and that will be no earlier than
June 1st now I understand it's natural
for people to question why they can't do
one or other thing now why certain
distinctions have been made but in
reality you have to look at the package
of measures as a whole mindful of the
risks of the are level and taking into
account the various different economic
and social effects combined so we've
adopted a balanced approach guided at
all
time's by the science and as I said the
overriding need to avoid a second peak
that could overwhelm the NHS of course
it's true to say that making any changes
inherently comes with some risk of
spreading the virus compared to simply
staying at home but it's also true that
staying in permanent lockdown is itself
not sustainable on health grounds or
economic grounds
that's why we've only used measures
where it can be done with the lowest
risk possible and that's also why we're
watching the impact of every change that
we make very closely I know the last
couple of months have been really tough
for families for businesses for everyone
up and down the UK but it's only by
keeping to the plan sticking to the
rules even including when those rules
change that we will beat coronavirus for
good slide three please and that's why
we've asked people to stay alert to
control the virus to save lives as we
make changes to the measures in place in
England and adjust the government's
advice accordingly now for the vast
majority of people that still means
staying at home as much as possible for
those that can't work from home they
should return to work with the
arrangements in place to ensure that it
can be safely and responsibly done we've
also adjusted as you can see from the
slides the advice to allow people to
exercise more to visit public outdoor
spaces but staying two metres apart from
those outside their own household and as
ever people need to keep washing their
hands regularly and carrying out the
hygiene measures that we've advertised
before our advice is to wear a face
covering when you're outside the home in
enclosed spaces and where it's difficult
to socially distance for example if
going to the shops or traveling on
public transport and if you or anyone in
your household develop symptoms then you
still all need to self isolate now while
we're asking the public to do these
things we in government will keep
ramping up the effort that we need to
see to get the UK back to him all
way of living and with that in mind
today the health secretary announced
that anyone in the UK with Kovac 19
symptoms can now get a test by booking
online and I can also report that we've
recruited now over 21,000 contact
tracers and cool handlers in England for
the implementation of our tests and tres
program that program is absolutely key
in the next steps that we need to take
as a country you can come through this
pandemic safely and responsibly Jonathan
if you'd like to run us through the
latest data Thank You Secretary of State
good afternoon everybody I've just got a
few data slides to show you in the
normal fashion beginning with this one
which shows you Apple maps searches for
directions so it is confined to Apple
users and it shows the beginning of the
period of lockdown on the left on the
23rd of March and what has happened to
searches for walking instructions
driving instructions and public
transport from that point until the very
recent past and you can see that there
has been a gradual but only gradual
upward trend in searches related to
walking and driving but for public
transport this trend is essentially flat
and this is very much in line with the
guidance that the government has issued
about avoiding public transport wherever
possible saving it for key workers and
clearly this is a trend that the public
are following I've shown you the two
data points on the right of the slide
before now that compared with last year
44% of adults are working at home in the
period 24th of April to the 3rd of May
compared with 12% at the same time last
year and that 80 percent of adults
report they have either left the home
for permitted reasons or not at all in
that period next slide please
moving on now to testing these data are
correct as
that oh nine hundred hours this morning
and they relate to tests processed and
sent out and the broad message is that
we are continuing to test at the rate of
around 100,000 tests per day and that in
total almost 2.7 million tests have been
used since the crisis began and in terms
of confirmed cases the data as of this
morning were overnight for two thousand
six hundred and eighty four new cases
out of a grand total of diagnosed cases
of just under a quarter of a million but
what you can see if you look to the
bottom right hand corner of the slide
the green bars you can now see a
definite and sustained decline in new
confirmed cases which continues to be
encouraging next slide so these are data
I showed to you last week updated of
course data from hospitals the top curve
relates to estimated admissions with
kovat 19 in England 678 is the latest
figure down from 701 on the 9th of May
so again steady declines and you can see
that in the top blue curve turning at
the bottom of the slide to the
percentage of critical care beds
currently occupied by covert 19 patients
this trend is also consistently down
across the four nations and currently
the figure runs at nineteen percent next
slide please
and then this slide also relates to
hospitals it relates to all of the UK
and it relates to the total number of
people in hospital with kovat 19 over
time updated as of the 17th of May and
what you can see here is that everywhere
the numbers of patients in hospital with
kovat 98
is now in sustained decline again very
good news and the final slide please
this is the the daily deaths data these
are deaths confirmed with a positive
test in the UK as of the 18th of May we
are reporting 160 deaths and a total of
three thirty four thousand seven hundred
and ninety-six with a positive test what
you can see and again it remains the
most important thing to look for is the
overall long-term trend as illustrated
by the orange line which is showing a
consistent and solid decline as the days
and weeks roll by